all right B let's finish out strong with
something super cool turning on social
this is what I'm
[Music]
liking so there is a series of videos
that have been taking TiK ToK by storm
it's simply a model on the London
Underground lipsyncing and dancing
during her train ride it is awesome she
is known as tube girl her videos often
captured tens of millions of views and
has led to the copycat tube girl Trend
she's even had some big names co-star in
her videos including Ginger spies young
blood and choice saon uh we have tube
girl AKA Sabrina with us now come on
over Sabrina looking
beautiful just stunning so how did this
start oh my God so I graduated
University in June and then I moved
congratulations thank you yeah so I
finished law school and I was like you
know what I cannot you finished law
school we're just skipping over that
okay all right yeah it was a bit of a
tough one and I thought to myself you
know what I'm not going to do this for
my life um and I just was getting into
anything that I could possibly do that
was creative so I was alone in my house
in London in summer and I was thinking
okay what can I do I started listening
to loads of music I started dancing
around in my house so I went down to the
tube and I was on the way to my friend's
house and I was just like listening to
my music and I was like bopping my head
and then the wind like hits me like and
I had my hair like all blown out and I
was like you know what would look so
good right now if I like recorded myself
so you so much so you get on the tube
and you just make these video what are
people doing while you're making the
videos London doesn't care oh my God are
they literally just like like they look
and they're like no I can't deal with
this today and you know what I'm like
you know what I'm just going to do my
thing they really love like not caring
about what's around them everyone's in
their own head that this is what I love
about New York I moved here and
everybody is in their own world doing
their own thing oh my God I did it hear
and I brought leaf blower cuz you don't
have wind
here oh my God girl wait so you are
walking around with somebody just
like a leaf blower is a lot of wind and
nobody
cared I love this city so much okay so I
was like this is my first time in New
York my first time in America ever oh
welcome thank you I made it Mom I made
it m oh that's awesome well thank you so
much Sabrina I'm liking your post right
now so we've hit the end of the show um
and this is usually we give our guest
$1,000 courtesy of our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show did you
know that well it's true since Sabrina
is doing so well um you know since she's
doing so well for herself we are we
thought we'd give it to someone in the
audience so are you cool with that are
you cool with that anybody want $1,000
here all right I want you to look at
that screen and the money is going to
whoever the camera lands on let's do
where is she I can't see oh I was trying
to find you wow hi what first of all I
love your sweater girl and wait what
what is your name I'm a little shook
right now I was not expecting uh my name
is Emmy L I love that name what are you
going to do with $1,000 great all
getting married next year so that's
going to go straight to the marriage
part
congratulations yes what a beautiful way
to celebrate that's amazing you're
amazing we'll have it spend it on your
dress that's what I say maybe I'll spend
it on like the
booze you know what that's a better
pick dresses come and go but people
getting drunk at wedding receptions last
for Timeless Timeless Timeless well
enjoy your wedding and congratulations
that's awesome
thank you so much to Saina for joining
us and thank you to all our guests team
and Thompson Shan Paul Manel teriso
Karen and Rick and of course Sterling
surpris awesome have a great day and if
it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home